we gotta talk first ever Grammy
nomination this is huge first of all
congratulations thank you this is cool
this is amazing how did you react when
you first found out that you were
getting I need to hear the reaction yeah
it was like it was morning and like we
were out early before early morning
we were out the night before so like we
were half asleep and like we didn't know
exactly what time they would announce or
name maybe like the categories we were
in so like Thomas was asleep I was
having a shower Ethan was nowhere to
find so Damiana was the only one like
watching it and streaming and then like
from the shower I started hearing like
crazy screaming and swear words in
Italian and then he starts banging on my
door and I was like what did I do wrong
and then he's like we're loving able
program
there's no other reaction that's the
best reaction good reaction excitement
excitement right that's amazing did you
ever think when you first started making
music like this could be
a point in your life that you can get to
Grammy nominated not really yeah
that's young right very unexpected yeah
yeah who who in your life had the the
best reaction when you told them family
friends who who do you think gave you
the best reaction to this actually I
haven't told anyone of my really members
I mean I mean this is
of course the news and the stuff I
didn't I didn't talk with them I would
say with our friends I don't know I
thought we our my friends and it was
like oh my God real so I thought you
were pranking them yeah I thought it was
a joke
always possible I mean yeah yeah
oh my God okay I love that
um so at this point of your lives
reaching this height of success is this
like the dream are you living the dream
right now is this are you more of a like
a I want more or is this you know I'm
living the dream right now yeah in
between like of course that we're living
a dream actually but there's some
there's always something more to aim for
so always moving the goal post looking
for the next thing this is just the
first step we're looking at many more
Grammy nominations coming up yeah
so if you weren't doing this right now
if you weren't grammy-nominated artists
what do you think you'd be doing like
what were you doing before all this took
off how are you making money were you
making money no were you with the
parents like what were you what were you
up to yeah we were like too young I
think because we started playing
together when we were like 15 years old
okay so we didn't like we just went to
high school yeah no plan B but I think
yeah I think it's very lucky that we got
to do this because I don't know
all your eggs were in this basket yes
you're like there is no plan B here this
is this is it for us you know make it
break I love that so back in high school
do you still talk to friends in high
school like what are they thinking of
work like they saw you guys making music
back then did they ever think that you
could amount to this or what are they
saying now seeing you out of Grandma I
think they lived like the same
experience as us like we did it together
because like when we started playing at
like School parties or the stuff all of
our friends were there like back at the
time so they like kind of grew up and
saw this whole thing happening step by
step us so they're with you every step
of the way yeah that's amazing that's
amazing so I always ask are you used to
being celebrities some people are
natural born celebrities you guys kind
of blew up after you won the Eurovision
yeah so how do you feel being out in the
streets as a celebrity do people ever
come up to you and you're just like no
I'm not we're not them like you know
what I mean yeah
[Applause]
oh my God you know you look very similar
to Victoria Vermont yeah everyone tells
them yeah
but they must look at you guys and like
you know you dress a bit different there
must be like you guys must be someone
you know like if I saw you guys today
I'd be like okay tomorrow's like you got
to be someone yeah
you look like yeah
you look like a bag
also like in Italy sometimes it happens
that the people like come to you and and
like they say you and then they ask you
is it you yeah and I'm like
I am me I mean I mean so until they
don't say my name like I'm like maybe
yeah perhaps to be maybe I don't know
look me up
I love that I love that so with all the
successes you guys have experienced so
far do you feel pressure coming up into
your album Rush is coming out obviously
in January do you feel like there's a
lot of pressure on you guys to perform
and with that album or how do you feel
with the release of that I will say that
we feel just happiness I mean because we
have yeah we happy to release our music
so it's the first part of I mean it's
one of the first part for us of course
with this music and play live and this
kind of stuff so we we say basically we
always happy to release new music and
our crowd our fans basically so now we
didn't feel the pressure I will say also
I'd say like when it comes to the
creative process like writing music we
try to really not think about all the
pressure and people that are gonna
listen and judge it because other
otherwise it really kills I think your
Vibe when you're making it it's like you
start thinking about too many things and
really you lose the natural process you
know so when when it's about music we
just try to like
travel back in time to when we were 16
and in the studio and just having fun
right because you always hear some
artists you know when they start trying
to make music for the fans that you
think that they'll like it doesn't go as
well yeah so you guys try to kind of
stick to your your passion and yeah and
stay with them yeah I love that I love
that for sure um so yeah Rush is coming
out in January super excited for that
what's the tone of this album what do
you what message are you trying to
portray to the fans with this album
um I think that like it's in a certain
way is the complete opposite of the
latest album because with the latest one
that we did we tried to find like a
common path and and follow it and this
album Rush is gonna be uh like the
celebration of our differences we we
started from the four different
individuality of us and we're actually
very different one from the other with
different musical taste and musical
background and musical ideas so we try
to use it as a as an advantage
that's amazing yeah yeah no Advantage
yeah exactly I think a lot of the times
when you see a band you think of them as
a unit one one unit but you are
individuals yeah you all come from
different walks of life so that's very
important that this album is going to
show that for you guys that's that's
really amazing
um I was just listening to the loneliest
on the way here
um great song I love a sad song You Know
I watched a music video too amazing you
actually fell into that water was that
was that real yeah a few times yeah you
actually did that oh she actually fell
back into the water like that that was
hard that that looked a little scary
it's a little yeah okay
so speaking of lonely I'm wondering you
guys on tour do you ever feel lonely
obviously there's four of you you're
together but in the grand scheme of
things do you ever feel lonely being
away from your family being away from
your friends like how does that go I
think like generally this kind of
lifestyle of course it sometimes it's
very weird because like of course now as
we travel a lot we started to like meet
a lot of people in different cities so
we kind of have like friends everywhere
we go so that's good of course and it
helps you like to be in a state of mind
where it looks like a normal life but
when you travel Parts where you've never
been you know then every day you're like
in a different city and you don't know
anyone and you have to play every night
so you see like thousands of people but
then you don't really have like that
natural human contact with many so of
course sometimes you get to feel a lot
lonely and you're far from your family
friends and whoever like from your
hometown so I think in this we're very
lucky to be like the four of us and of
course also the people we're working
with so our team of their we're all like
a big family you know so that really
helps I love that that's amazing yeah
yeah
and the thing that
the the sun kind of I always felt this
kind of paradox behind the distance and
traveling a lot and being and being of
course
apart from our families and our friends
and stuff because of course this kind of
Lifestyle
it makes you kind of in this position
so it's kind of something you have to
deal with but the Paradox I think is
is that even though you're fires from
your families and friends from like the
usual time of your life in general
because you're working a lot
this kind of makes you even closer to
them because you miss them a lot and why
are you missing them you also want them
to use so it's kind of it's kind of
interesting to see both sides or the
same thing yeah also it's beautiful
because when you're back you enjoy even
more you know right so like the small
things that you'd give for granted every
day then you like really appreciate them
so even just having another dinner with
the family and stuff absolutely I kind
of relate for sure you know I'm in a
long distance relationship right now and
it's like the distance makes you care
about the person more and when you're
with each other it you just appreciate
the time more whereas you take it for
granted when you're with each other
every day right so it's kind of the same
thing I know I don't want to throw my
relationship on you guys but that's it I
do relate I do relate okay and we're
always trying again you know what I mean
exactly so